all right Biden's lying about his house
fire got us all thinking about the other
things he's been lying to us about now
this is an ongoing problem with him you
can't say it's because he's old because
he's been doing this literally for
decades so let's get back into the time
machine let's go back to 1987. then
Senator Joe Biden he was 44. no signs of
dementia senility then and for some
reason bragging about how smart he was
I think I probably have a much higher IQ
than you do I suspect I went to law
school on a full academic scholarship
and in fact ended up in the top half of
my class and I'd be delighted to sit
down and compare my IQ to yours
okay
here are the facts he got a half
scholarship and not a full one and it
was based on financial need not in his
great intellect he also graduated 76 in
a class of 85. not in the top half all
right the next lie
30 years ago Nelson Mandela walked out
of prison and entered into discussions
about apartheid I had the great honor of
meeting him I had the great honor of
being arrested with our U.N Ambassador
on the streets of Soweto trying to get
to see him on Robbins Island
it's Soweto isn't it anyway the
Washington Post actually gave Biden four
Pinocchio's on that one and said there's
no evidence to support it all right
there's another arrest story though this
time while he was protesting for civil
rights
because I'm so damn old I was there as
well seems like yesterday the first time
I got arrested anyway
all right the New York Times said there
is no evidence that he was ever arrested
during a civil rights protest
that has to be it right no if there's
more Biden claimed he watched the
Pittsburgh bridge collapse and with his
own eyes
Pittsburgh is a city of bridges more
bridges in Pittsburgh than any other
city in America
I watched that bridge collapse
I got there and saw a collapse
didn't happen unless he has owl-like
eyesight because from the pool reports
that day the president had been told of
the bridge collapse in Pittsburgh he
wasn't there now I could keep this going
all night okay one more
I used to drive a tractor-trailer oh
awesome and so I'm a little bit about
driving big trucks
now the White House tried really really
hard to prove that one to be correct but
it turns out the president rode once in
an 18-wheeler
so the lies keep coming
and the left keeps allowing them to come
unchecked so I think all of us need to
ask ourselves if he's willing to lie
about something as silly as driving an
18-wheeler
what else is he lying to us about hey
Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else